you're mine who the tryna Buddha Marcel
dignity to Nanjing laughing bubbling
momentum the city I shall
lady the high-level feed the power
my mother is whatever tolerate that gets
involved in sisters in the offense what
we had to doing well it's a beautiful
day we're in a beautiful months or is
Ramadan or fasting enough a little share
a little reminded with you guys this is
going to be probably one of the shorter
videos I've ever done yet looking very
simple and I'm going to show you a
practical example of what I'm talking
about
now as you guys know the Prophet
Muhammad peace be upon him inside
Bukhari printed form of uranium and I
was pleased with in that the message of
our workings of this world what we
haven't said when ramadan comes the
gates of paradise opened the gates of
hell are closed and there was a chained
up now a lot people say hold on a second
it's the devil's are chained up then
wild committing sins why do I have this
old habits here so now I'm going to use
that mean good example yet so what I'm
going to do is put my laptop away now I
need you guys to get close let's go over
here okay okay all right as you can see
guys imagine this is the Shaitaan yeah
okay stirring up trouble I'll just put
this leaf in there so you guys can see
the motion we'll stir in it yeah okay so
the shaitaan eleven months of our life
is dead and he's Corden you know fit
mass whispers whispers Shaitaan is
stirring up trouble stirring up trouble
so what happens is when the Shaitaan
goes has a stirring stopped no it hasn't
it's carrying on yeah now what this
means well insisted is that the Shaitaan
when he comes around and he's causing
trouble when he leaves his left us with
bad habits now that if you just
understand one thing is that eventually
this is disturbing but going to come to
a stop yeah
now which that shows us that when the
Shaitaan is locked up and by the way
just what to mention is that the
narration said in Arabic that it's the
big shouting the ones that call the
Dixons and one with the most power yeah
Moshe is a lot of other ones still there
however even though that a lot of the
cause of this trouble is that eventually
when they leave and they're locked up
you still they left you with these bad
habits so now it's the time for you
since they are not here is to eventually
put that servant to a stop how by
battling those the bad habits of
Shaitaan has left you with so it's this
time the perfect time everyone are done
and those who called you guys normal
that was in some individuals yes it is
Ramadan Muslims how many people have
made big changes in Ramadan so it's this
time of month that we work on it to get
rid of blogs bad habits so I thought
this might change Ramadan and make you
understand the concept of [ __ ] zombie
novel etc so make sure guys where could
you find us a lot don't be playing
through videos enemies huh just keeping
a lot love the best thing about love is
those who commit and do the fun apps so
let's work on that beautiful Ramadan I
saw Molly for whatever that schedule if
you want to do any more videos related
to Amazon link the comment section below
and don't forget to watch my latest
video ten to three and not to you know
matter
assalamu alaikum
for the head shoo-shoo shoo-shoo hey
give me one I'm sorry
subscribe